Seiya, I thought
you were smarter than this!
If you won't give up, then I'm
gonna have to tear you apart!
[roars]
[groaning]
[Marin] Seiya, burn your Cosmo!
Focus your body and spirit
to the strike point,
to your hand!
[yells]
What the hell?
Cassios! You can't
lose the Armor to Seiya!
[growls] I won't.
Cassios, I don't want
to have to hurt you.
If you surrender,
you can still walk away.
[chuckles]
You won't be
walking away from this. [grunts]
I won't let you win the Armor!
[roars]
What?
You just don't get it, do you?
You use Cosmo, but you use
only a fraction of its power.
What are you saying?
[Seiya] You've never even seen
the universe
within your own body.
[Marin] Huh. As if
you've already mastered it.
[Cassios]
The universe in my body?!
[Seiya grunts]
You can do better
if you can utilize all your Cosmo.
You and the stars
are made of the same atoms.
In the beginning,
everything in the universe
was born from the Big Bang.
Your body is
its own mini-universe.
True Knights can generate power
by igniting their own Cosmo.
They can split the Earth
and smash the stars.
Seiya, burn your Cosmo.
Make your inner universe
explode.
Then your attacks will hit
with all the power of a meteor.
Seiya's hands are tracing
the 13 stars of Pegasus!
I'm bigger. I'm stronger.
I'm a lot smarter than you.
You don't have a universe
inside your body!
No, Cassios!
Get away from Seiya!
[Seiya] Pegasus Ryu-Sei-Ken!
What?!
[yells]
[groaning]